ya que estás de la artista
multidisciplinaria cubra academy es un
claro ejemplo de ello con hilo de oro el
jacuzzi o una pila de chaquetas son los
restos militares que se convirtieron en
un símbolo conmovedor de la retirada
estadounidense de afganistán natal cubra
academy se vio obligada a huir de kabul
tras una controvertida actuación
artística en 2015 que le valió amenazas
de muerte se refugió en francia y el año
pasado ayudó a sacar a decenas de
artistas afganos del país cuando los
talibanes volvieron en agosto mientras
que un nuevo informe de la onu destacó
cientos de violaciones de derechos
humanos en afganistán lo mandaron de la
cadena francesa de france 24 se sentó
con ella en avignon y le preguntó cuál
es el papel de los artistas en estos
tiempos difíciles
el arte tiene la capacidad de cambiar
masivamente las mentalidades el arte
está mucho más adelantado en el tiempo
la artística en la escena artística
afgana desempeña un papel importante yo
se hace tan conocido porque llevo siete
años en francia jose
y he conocido a mucha gente es afín y
pasa al tuyo 7 en cada encuentro me
dicen que eres la primera mujer afgana
que conozco
y eso dice mucho de la imagen que la
gente tiene de afganistán desde fuera
son del exterior solo saben de los
talibanes solo saben de los terroristas
sólo saben de la guerra que a mi don
montaba artístic pero en mi trabajo
artístico cuestionó el papel del arte
que muestra que llama la atención que
propone y también muestra la riqueza de
mi país a copos metros y somoza la gente
como la gana cubra academy muchos
artistas asumen el reto de contar las
páginas más dolorosas de la historia de
sus países es lo que hizo el dibujante
francés que a vivir sobre la redada del
velódromo y ver una operación policial
en la que casi 13 mil judíos fueron
detenidos entre el 16 y el 17 de julio
de 1942 para ser exterminados en campos
de concentración un evento del cual sólo
se conoce una foto fue en 1967 que la
opinión pública conoció la implicación
del estado y de la policía francesa en
la redada gracias al impactante libro de
dos antiguos resistentes comunistas por
ley
de este relato nacieron 16 dibujos en
blanco y negro publicados en una revista
este año se celebra los 80 años de la
realidad del vélib y por primera vez
estas obras se exponen en el mundo real
de la shoá una muestra aún más simbólica
porque que avivarse parte de los
dibujantes que fueron asesinados en el
atentado terrorista contra saliendo el 7
de enero de 2015
del otro lado del océano atlántico en
eeuu otra exposición se estrenó en las
calles de nueva york el quinto festival
de fotografía latinoamericana organizado
por el bronx documentary centre presenta
obras a gran escala de fotógrafos
premiados tanto emergentes como
consagrados procedentes de colombia
argentina chile venezuela méxico y el
salvador entre otros países expuestas
por todo el barrio de melrose en el sur
del bronx retratan la familia la memoria
la migración y otras cuestiones sociales
se pueden ver hasta el 31 de julio
[Música]
al igual que los fotógrafos expuestos en
el latinoamérica en photo festival a la
cantautora maya sara curuchet busca
visibilizar la riqueza cultural de su
pueblo es la primera artista indígena
guatemalteca en llevar a nivel
internacional cantus en español y en
cachi que la su idioma materno a través
de su gira actual mujer indígena sara
curuchet tiene conciertos previstos en
guatemala pero también españa en agosto
y luego méxico-estados unidos y honduras
nuestra corresponsal habló con ella
sobre la dimensión política de cantar en
escenarios del mundo entero en un idioma
maya cantábrico si quieres eso el poder
acercarme con mucho amor también a esa
sexualidad y esa sabiduría que tienes
que tiene un pueblo que tienen dos
diferentes pueblos es una manera también
de transmitir el sistema racista es una
forma también detrás de vivir el sistema
colonial que impone muchas veces en el
español como la única como el único
idioma que en el que se tendría que
hablar pero si no están acá en guatemala
hay más de 22 a 22 idiomas mayas y es
muy hermoso compartirlo al mundo entero
que los idiomas y los con los indígenas
somos culturas vivas otra artista que
toma posición a través de su música la
estrella del pop rock pink estreno y
real events última que responde
directamente a la decisión del tribunal
supremo de anular el derecho al aborto y
que aborda otros de los problemas más
acuciantes de eeuu como el racismo la
homofobia o los tiroteos en las escuelas
[Música]
nos despedimos con la nueva colaboración
entre los raperos franceses es bien
jaakkola ovoide soy su vídeo grabado en
la capital de costa de energía y yo
gracias por su confianza y cuídense
al desarrollo
ella
[Música]
[Aplausos]
son
[Música]